some frontline healthcare workers are
still experiencing shortages of safety
gear known as ppe about a year into the
pandemic now
a non-profit group called get us ppe
says requests from health care workers
seeking help to get the equipment
rose 260 percent between november
and december one doctor is telling us
about frustrations at her former
hospital in michigan
when she tried to make sure staff were
safe consumer investigative
correspondent anna werner joins us
and a good morning to you good morning
this doctor says she tried everything
she could to make sure nurses at her
hospital were better protected
and still she says it wasn't enough
the city of alpena in northeast michigan
sits on the shores of lake huron
with a population of just under 10 000
people
and just one hospital where doctor and
victory worked
at night it was just me in the er doc
and anything that happened in the
hospital i had to take care of and i
really liked that challenge
in april her hospital's president was
asked about preparations for the coming
pandemic
and he told a local tv station we have
enough supplies to manage
an influx of patients but that's not
what dr victory says her review as part
of the hospital's medical executive
committee found
what i saw when i actually went to the
medical floors
was that we weren't using the right
precautions
the staff wasn't safe and therefore the
patients weren't safe
then in mid-november she says the crisis
she was worrying about
hit the icu was full the medical floors
were full
and the covid unit was full of covid
patients
and she says nurses were being told to
reuse critical n95
masks by the time the hospital decided
the mask was worn out
it had been mourned way more than was
recommended and it wasn't working
we were wearing the same ass over and
over and over again
and this hospital worker whose identity
is concealed because they fear getting
fired
says staff were even afraid to ask for
new masks
we weren't testing the staff and they
were coming down with kovid
and getting sick and they were scared to
go
back to take care of more covid patients
around thanksgiving dr victory became so
concerned she says
she decided to use her own money to
purchase seven
government approved respirators called
peppers one for herself
the others to give to the nurses so i
took
all of the money that i had i spent
about seven thousand dollars and bought
seven peppers and i took them into the
hospital without the documentation
and the hospital told us not to use them
she says managers then took them away
and locked them up
it was actually taking
the protective equipment away from
people who wanted it
we wanted to know why but mid-michigan
health declined our request for an
interview
instead saying in a statement that the
safety of all our front line workers
employees volunteers and patients has
been and will always remain a top
priority
and they said they've followed ppe
standards
we asked dr shikha gupta about that
situation
sadly that's not a surprising story to
me
at this point in the pandemic dr gupta
heads the group
get us ppe which helps get medical gear
for workers
her group survey of frontline workers
found that nearly
90 percent said they are repeatedly
reusing masks
recommended to be used just once like
this hospital staff member in ohio who
asked not to be identified for fear of
losing her job
the most frustrating thing to me is
knowing that my safety is being
compromised every day
it's incredibly frustrating and as for
dr victory
on december 3rd she turned in her badge
and quit i said i can't do this
this is an unsafe situation and i can't
continue to be here
i wanted the hospital to be a safe place
for patients
and i wanted the hospital to be a safe
place to work
and it didn't seem like that was
anyone's goal
well mid michigan health told us they
are in compliance with state mandates
and cdc recommendations but gettis ppe
that group says there are still
challenges in the ppe supply chain
nationwide with some items
especially masks and gloves in
especially short supply
meanwhile gail dr victory is now working
at another hospital in a different state
again working 12-hour shifts with covid
patients
but people like dr victory are the
doctors that we really need at this
particular time thank you very much anne
i'm glad that she
is working someplace you know it's a bad
sign when a hospital worker has to
distort their voice
and and disguise their face to tell the
truth two of them about this
yeah and when a doctor has to go into
their own pocket to buy equipment they
think their colleagues need seven
thousand dollars into their own pocket
it's really distressing
when hospitals which should know about
safety precautions aren't following them
somebody got some explaining to do there